welcome to the Macmillan report I'm
Marilyn wokes your host and today our
guest is Professor Francesca travail
Otto a professor of history at Yale
professor trovato specializes in the
social and economic history of Italy
continental Europe and the Mediterranean
in the early modern period she's the
author of a book on Venetian glass
manufacturing and she has also published
several essays on craft guilds women's
work and merchant networks we were going
to talk with her today about her newest
book the familiarity of strangers the
Sephardic diaspora Livorno and
cross-cultural trade in the early modern
period
welcome professor trovato very nice to
meet here maryland's okay in your newest
book which will be out in May you look
at you take a new approach to
cross-cultural trade
tell us a little bit about the premise
in a long history of European and
Western thought and to some extent in
larger popular imagination Commerce and
toleration often go hand-in-hand and
historically it's true that society that
have engaged in trade with groups of
different religious and ethnic
background especially port cities or
coastal society tend to be more upper
mobile more open-minded if we want but
we also know that historically trade has
coexisted with war conquest with the
segregation of merchants group within
for example with in port cities and with
religious prejudice more more generally
so the premise of of this book is that
in order to trade across religious and
ethnic boundaries merchants need to have
some understanding of each other's
culture at the very least they
to have a language in common sometimes
they hire translators but they need to
be able to communicate they need to have
a sense of what legal norms can be used
in order to adjudicate potential
disputes and how to find recourse in
case of fraud but merchants need not to
embrace each other culture you know
fully so that you can trade with
somebody if you have enough trust that
say they will repay your credit they
will fulfill your orders they will abide
by the promises that make to you but it
doesn't mean if you're a merger that you
want to marry your daughter to them or
that you want to invite them to the same
place of worship where you go quickly
for example okay and what drew you to
this topic I'm fascinated by how market
relations work in different times and in
different places and the history of
Europe between around 1500 and 1800
which is the period that historians
called the early modern period it's
particularly fascinating because this is
a time when European societies became
more open more uh permobil when certain
stigma against merchants they kind of
begun to decline in comparison to the
previous a feudal period it's also a
period when certain religious groups and
ethnic diasporas that were heavily
involved in trade including Jews are
given unprecedented rights relatively to
the time period in part because of the
perceived commercial abilities of these
groups and yet at the same time European
society in this period in the early
modern period remained very hierarchical
and segregation persisted and religious
prejudice are persisted so I was
interested first of all in understanding
how cross-cultural trade could work in
this context and also what it might mean
for the people involved in it and
I say this because we tend to assume
that you know Jews traded with Jews or
Quakers traded with trader excuse me
Quakers traded with Quakers or Hugo
knows traded with humour knows and on
the other hand some historians and some
scholars in the social sciences tend to
assume that for these communities to
trade with each other there need to be a
modern legal system that emerges and
that adjudicate disputes when they arise
but the everyday reality of trade I
found was more complicated and in fact
social and legal forms of enforcement of
commercial obligations tended to coexist
so why live Lorna why did you choose
this city in Italy and give us an idea
of where it's located in Italy as well
Livorno is a coastal port city in
Tuscany and I was drawn to Livorno by
both intellectual and scholarly reason
and to some extent by chance and my
interest in Livorno has to do with the
fact that most European scholarship on
early modern global trade focuses on the
Atlantic and to some extent of the
Indian Ocean and we tend to forget that
the Mediterranean continued to be an
important geopolitical and commercial
area and the one in particular was a
major international hub in the late 16th
and early 17th century the Medici Grand
Dukes of Tuscany
transformed a small village into a large
international port city and Livorno in
fact has an English version of its name
it's called Leghorn because it was the
British outpost in the Mediterranean
there were a number of foreign and
religious and ethnic minorities who
operated there as merchants and in
particular which was a part of my
interest Livorno was a had a very large
community of Iberian Jews Sephardic Jews
the descendants of those Jews who had
been expelled from Spain and for
ninety-two the largest community of
Sephardic Jews in Europe and the new
world was in Amsterdam and it studied
has been studied quite a lot and Livorno
has not been studied very much and when
I say that I was also drawn to laverna
by chance is because one of the reason
why Livorno has not been investigated as
much as others say you know London or
Philadelphia or more well-known port
cities is because it's archival records
a rather poor part were destroyed in the
late 19th century and then during the
bombings of world war ii part went into
flames and i came across by chance i
came across a collection of 13,000 670
business letters that a jewish
partnership in Livorno had written in
the early 18th century to a large
variety of business agents across
mediterranean the Mediterranean Europe
and the Indian Ocean and as I began to
read these letters I found that a
considerable number was addressed to
Christian Catholic particulate merchants
and even to a group of Hindu merchants
in in Goa in Porton which was the
capital of Portuguese India at the time
and I thought that was really
fascinating and I was hooked mm-hmm that
is very interesting so let's talk a
little bit in specifics about their
research you've done I imagine you've
had to travel to lavona which I imagine
was pretty wonderful what else did you
have to do in order to pull the book
together well so these are Jewish
merchants who lived and traded lived in
leborgne and traded from there
were part of an intercontinental
diaspora and also as these letters show
they had extended extensive and and
durable commercial relations with
merchants communities very far
geographically and culturally from them
so I decided to follow the traces you
know to follow the footsteps of these
of these merchants letters and it was
not enough for me to do the research in
Tuscany in order to appreciate the
global dimension of their commercial
activities in Lisbon I found a lot of
interesting material in the archives of
the parish church in which Genoese and
Florentine merchants Catholic merchants
who traded regularly with the Jews in
Livorno congregated in Goa in India I
found some very interesting business
letters written by a group of Hindu
merchants who traded with Europeans
regularly and who were able to do so
partially because they acquire the
etiquette and the standards of business
letter-writing that also had some legal
implications in Paris and in Marseilles
I found a lot of documents that
documented the activities of the Jews of
Livorno in the Mediterranean because in
their commercial activities in the
Ottoman Empire the Jews of Livorno were
under French diplomatic protection in
London I found a lot of last wills
Testaments of Jews of Livorno who
invested part of their money in the
British stock exchange
and public debt in the Netherlands I
found a really interesting lawsuits that
then are related to the bankruptcy of
the partnership I was working on and at
some point a colleague of mine in the
history department at Yale suggested
that I looked at library in Minnesota
where in fact there was a cachet of
letters that was relevant to my project
so it was a lot of fun and really I had
to try to follow a little bit on the on
the under footsteps of these the truly
global partnerships and one of the
interesting things you found in your
research was that business cooperation
could coexist with mistrust Evette with
other social and cultural aspects
explain that phenomenon a little bit in
fact i think that if we appreciate the
technology of trade in this period and
the legal social
cultural organization of European
society in this period we shouldn't be
too surprised by the fact that Economic
Cooperation could go together with
religious mistrust by technology of
trade I mean that long-distance trade
was very risky this was before the
steamship was invented before the
Telegraph existed before International
Tribunal at which you could I you know I
that could adjudicate disputes and
commercial matters came into existence
and that is part of the reason why it
was often the case that merchants will
rely on family members or on
co-religionist in order to conduct their
business across long distances not
because family members or
co-religionists are naturally more you
know competent or more trustworthy but
because it's easier to monitor them and
because they have greater incentives to
fulfill their commercial obligation but
there's more and there is that really
that economic cooperation it's not
synonymous with cultural appreciation so
you could find business letters in which
say a Christian merchant who trades
regularly with individual Jewish
merchants also includes comments that
are derogative and stereotypical about
Jews as a collective and what enduring
your research did you find to be most
surprising I was surprised by the extent
of the connections that existed between
the Mediterranean and the Indian Ocean
in this period the items of trade where
the Mediterranean red coral was exported
to India where it was highly valued and
it was bartered exchanged with Indian
diamonds and other precious stones I was
surprised by the extent to which the
Jews of Livorno were central to this
intercontinental trade and particularly
because by this period very few of them
would travel there in person
and so they did not know did not had met
personally the hinder traders to whom
they entrusted their business and
instead they relied on this a very
highly standardized etiquette of
business right of business letter
writing I was also surprised by the fact
that the business partnership on which I
focused the authors of these voluminous
correspondence went bankrupt
not because they were let down by one of
these distant Hindu agents who they
never met in person but because they at
some point entered into an ill-fated
business venture
with a Persian Jew in the attempt to
sell a 60 carat diamond which is a very
large diamond that which they brought
first to Versailles the French king's
court and later tried to sell on the
auction market for diamonds in London
and Amsterdam and it turned out the
diamond was not of the quality that they
had hoped and expected but also that the
Iranian Jew with whom they had entered
into business was not as reliable as
they had anticipated so I was surprised
that by the kind of tensions within the
broadest world of Jewish business that I
had investigated thank you very much for
being with us here today and sharing
some of your book with us the
familiarity of strangers for more
information about Professor trovato and
true research please visit our website
at yale.edu backslash Macmillan report
be sure to join us again for another
episode of the Macmillan report made
possible through funding from the
Whitney and Betty Macmillan Centre for
International and area studies at Yale
you